really great news while I was away I
ended I was supposed to be away for a
lot of this week there were some snafus
on my international travel which we
maybe we'll get to it in a little bit
maybe I'll tell you in a few weeks but
anyway I'm back here that's the bright
side I get to speak with all of you in
the mem
segmentum uh but the one day that I
missed was the announcement
of bent key which is the daily wire kids
entertainment offering and I was I was
following it you know I'm kind of
checking my phone I sent out some
tweets I've known about this project
obviously for years at this point this
is a project years in the making and
then I checked out the little
Sizzle hi you made it oh hello want to
play I've seen enough these two are
ready ready or not here we
go please keep your arms and legs inside
the cart at all times hurry up the party
is starting soon yeah follow me where is
he going we're going on a treasure hunt
we're exploring the wild blue yonder
it's Chilla
time pretty incredible it's
unbelievable whether big or little
little or
big we all have fabulous adventures
together wow it's time to head off for
adventure look around you all we need is
a bit of music Dr
solo imagine
this all I see is
Adventure I'm not a super sentimental
guy okay but I'm not going to say that
when I saw the sizzle tears came to my
eyes because I'm a man okay I'm a manly
man and I don't do that kind of thing
but I already had very high expectations
for for bent key for the kids offering
Jeremy had promised to invest I think it
was $100 million over the course of a
few years he did that about 18 months or
so ago and everyone kept asking where's
where's the kids entertainment where's
the kids entertainment and he not only
did he make good on it it is it is like
five time five to 10 times better even
than I expected it to be and I had high
expectations we've got four original
kids series a bunch of other kids series
from around the world that we've
acquired for this platform that are just
good content for your kids not crazy
woke stuff not going to convince them
that reality is upside down not overly
dactic and on the nose and just good fun
kids content that is going to help shape
their minds in the right way and is
going to entertain them I've I've been
playing it for my kids it's just it's
just amazing and if you are already a
daily wire annual member then there's
some great news you've already got full
access access to all of bent Key's
incredible shows at no extra cost this
would typically cost 99 bucks it is
included in your annual daily wire
membership for free this is the biggest
single biggest value ad we've ever given
in the dailywire membership uh you can
get bent key right now at dailywire.com
subscribe head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe we got so much more great
stuff coming but that it's just huge man
and some people are saying why is the
daily wire doing kids content what that
seems so odd this was always the point
this was always the point of daily wire
was not merely to comment on the culture
and politics which is important and we
do it I'm doing it right now but also to
make culture and politics that was the
point it's amazing to see it happen so
anyway go over there right now and
subscribe if you haven't already right
now go to Ruff greens.com
SL Michel you know I'm not the biggest
dog person in the world well my
stepbrother is and while I'm lukewarm on
my stepbrother I do think that the dog
should be healthy and so I sent my
stepbrother some rough greens and that
dog just keeps saying rough rough rough
because rough greens is so great for
dogs and dogs love it naturopathic
doctor Dennis black the founder of Ruff
greens is focused on improving the
health of every dog in America dog food
may as well be considered dead food
since it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition is not brown it's green
let rough greens bring your dog's food
back to life rough greens is a
supplement that can I I know how many
times I'm going to roll that are uh it
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food sprinkle little rough
Greens on the food every single day dog
owners are raving about it it supports
healthy joints improves Health boosts
energy levels so much more right now get
a free jumpstart trial bag so that your
dog can try it get a free jump start
trial bag delivered straight to your
door just a few business days go to Ruff
greens.com
rffg greens.com or call 844 ruff
rf123 ruff greens.com or call 844
rf123 today the business side of the of
the daily wire kids offering of bent key
is it's not just it's look it's
obviously primarily missionally driven
but the business side here is that 's a
huge marketing opportunity Disney all
the other woke companies they flip the
middle finger to Their audience okay you
say you don't want your audience's
eyeballs then we're going to take your
audience's eyeballs and we're going to
give them something you want to talk
about a big marketing opportunity for
conservatives broadly there's a new poll
out from AP n RC which says that uh 78%
of Americans believe the country is
trending in the wrong direction only
21% just a little over one in five
Americans say the US is headed in the
right direction this is a downturn even
from a month ago when that same group
found that three4 of Americans felt the
country was heading in the wrong
direction and a quarter believed it was
heading in the right direction so you
went from one in four Americans saying
the country is going in the right
direction down to one in five Americans
and and you're just in freefall
okay this is a great opportunity for any
Republican who says that he's running
for president right now or any
Republican who wants to be speaker of
the house that battle is going on right
the second too Ronald Reagan had a great
line in a time for choosing which is
maybe his most famous speech where he
said they accuse us of having simple
answers to complex problems maybe there
are simple answers not easy answers but
simple they are they are simple what do
we want in this country we want strong
families strong communities safe
communities Law and Order we want to be
able to flourish we want to be able to
prosper we want to we want more good and
less evil which means we want to worship
Our God we don't want our churches to be
closed we want to raise our kids in the
right way we we don't want weirdo
teachers in Crazy schools filling their
heads with a pack of Lies We don't
really simple we want to have borders we
want to have Law and Order we want there
to be a distinction between citizens and
foreigners we want to have a country we
want to have a country is that so crazy
and you got Democrats saying the
opposite of all of that no wonder that
more than three4 of Americans now say
the country is going in the wrong
direction what should Republicans do
Republicans should be normal they should
be normal they should say we want normal
things this was what was really
refreshing about Trump's rhetoric in
2016 is he wasn't reciting from some
political science textbook he wasn't
giving some abstract theory of whatever
people knocked him for it when he said
I'm running for president so we have
good strong communities there were
actually people on the right who came
out and said uh actually that's that's a
contradiction of federalism because the
president shouldn't want strong local
communities that should be the job of
the mayor and it's like shut up man shut
up nerd you Egghead stop it get your
head out of the textbook and put it into
reality with the political
community of course the man running for
president should want strong and safe
communities we want a good life that's
what we want that's what our founding
fathers wanted that's what our framers
wanted we want to secure the blessings
of liberty we don't want to put the card
before the horse and make an idol out of
some ideological
concept we want good normal stuff be
normal Republicans and you will much
more likely win elections boy what a
great clip that was
now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time